>>Marguerite: These kids aren't
just doing research to do research.
We're making sure kids are able to apply
the information across the curriculum
and in different aspects of life.
That's real world, that's a skill
kids need to leave high school with.
Our performance-based assessment
does come from that idea of rigor
and relevance, and the idea of it is
that your assessments require students
to think at a high level of rigor, so
that they're synthesizing information.
They're creating from the
information that they've garnered.
We're making sure kids are able
to apply critical thinking skills,
problem solving skills
across the curriculum
and in real world applications.
>>Kenneth: Can you apply the stuff
that we were talking about in class
to this new scenario that you
may or may not be familiar with?
In this case, a research project is
the performance-based assessment.
The project itself has
multiple components.
When I first made the assignment,
they see the rubric of how I'm going
to grade every component of it.
They have to make a model of their
compound using proper bond angles
and show relevance by what they're
using to make their model out of.
>>Student: One thing that is
being looked at is design--
>>Kenneth: The video component is where
they present the pros of their compound.
Instead of doing it as a straight
research and presentation,
I decided to change it into a
debate and amp up the project.
They picked similar compounds and
debate which one is the most effective.
>>Today our debate is diesel versus
octane and we're going to get rolling.
>>Student: The main use for octane
is as an ingredient in car fuel.
Even the supreme grade octane gasoline
isn't as expensive as diesel fuel is.
>>Kenneth: Through the rubric, part
of that is to discredit their opponent
and use their video against them,
so they have to have all this
research prepared ahead of time
and they're taking avid notes.
>>Student: Diesel fuel contains
about fourteen percent more
energy by volume than gasoline.
This gives it a significant
edge in fuel economy.
>>Student: If you had a forty-two
gallon barrel of petroleum,
twenty-one gallons would be able to be
used in gasoline and only about ten
to twelve would be for diesel.
>>Student: Luke also cleverly
leaves out how performance cars
such as trucks actually are...
>>Kenneth: The rubric for
the project is over half
of their fourth marking period grade.
The model and video, they both
have a sixty point weighting.
You've got the opposing argument, the
rebuttal, I gave it thirty points.
>>Student: So that's
ninety-eight percent
of normal people every day are
driving around gasoline engined cars.
>>Student: So diesel is the
future and it a way better fuel--
>>Kenneth: All the notes that I take
throughout the process could have been
just a comment made,
organization of their thoughts,
or things that were directly
defined in the rubric.
Like part of it is using their
opponent's video against them,
so if I see evidence, then I write that
down, so that I can go back and say,
"Look, here's why I'm
sliding it higher on the scale
or why I didn't slide it higher,
because I did not see this."
>>Marguerite: Kids own it, they
want to know the information.
Then they connect it to other things
that they know and it's theirs.
They retain it and they
can do more with it.
>>Kenneth: As a teacher, I was
trying to find a way to say,
"You might not remember every test or
every question I've ever given you,
but you will not walk out of those
school without remembering my class."
>>Student: You did good.
>>Student: Did I?
>>Student: Yeah.